Uh, hi, I'm Glenn Howerton, uh,
from AP bio and it's always sunny in Philadelphia.
And I'm going to answer some questions from the internet.
Yeah.
You are in an open field, armed with a baseball bat.
Picture that. Okay. How many, 10 year olds wearing bike helmets.
Could you take down before they get you?
So just a wave of ten-year-olds coming at you and game of Thrones.
It wouldn't matter. I'd get them all.
Absolutely infinite. I'd destroy those kids.
10 years old. Oh, they're.
I'd be John Snow. I'd be jealous. I'd be John Snow all over that.
Just ten-year-old bodies all over the place. It was a little idiots thing.
What are they going to do to me? Idiots?
Would you rather live in a world where everyone, but you is male or female?
Female. Female. Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah. Female, no doubt. Okay.
I find men to be extremely irritating. I, I prefer women on almost every level.
Do you think there are more porn stars or murders in the world now,
when you say murders, are we talking about like, uh,
people who have murdered or people who didn't desire to murder?
Not and, and Lee enjoyed murdering and want to murder more?
Not just like somebody who murdered. And it was like,
I feel bad if you kill the human. Oh, I see. Okay.
Anyone who is murdered? Uh, murders.
Yeah, the whole world here.
50,000 straight to your bank account or 500,000 in Penny's
can't convert the pennies. Ooh. Uh,
I'll go with $500,000 because, uh,
I think it'd be real fun to have to pay for something that's a thousand dollars
and bring in a ton of pennies. I just think that'd be easy. So yeah,
he's such an. One free throw shot.
If you make it, you get $1 million. If you miss it,
you can never text again. Do you take the shot? No,
I don't take the shot. What could you hit it? Do you,
are you okay on the back? You hit it. I can hit it, but it's still not worth it.
I mean, you know, you're rich, whatever. Yeah. I'm already rich. Ooh,
10 million. Yeah. I'd take the shot. I'd take the shot. Yep. Uh,
would you rather be the president, the Pope or the ruler of North Korea?
The president. Yeah, I can do it.
Look who's president right now. I think I got it. I think I got it.
Isn't Trump is going to do it, then I can definitely do that. Guy's a idiot.
Would you rather have a Dick as your nose
or nose as your Dick? Uh,
I mean, that's just crazy. Uh, uh,
I'd rather have a Dick as my nose. It's not,
it's gonna be bad for the acting career, but that pick something else.
Would you rather have your girlfriend's hair or your girlfriend or your
girlfriend has your hair? Oh, Hmm.
I think, uh, well it's my I,
that my girlfriend has my hair got good hair. What do you want from me?
That's good. That's good hair.
There were stats available for every aspect of your life.
What three stats would you would you want to see? Yeah, I'd be curious.
Like how many drinks have I had in a lifetime? That'd be, that'd be interesting.
Um, Oh,
how many people dislike me as a human being? Like, not,
not like the dislike me from television,
but like how many people have I like actually off in real life?
Cause I know, cause I've actually tried really hard not to,
to people off.
I actually consider myself kind of a good person in spite of the characters that
I play. Um, so, but I'm sure there are people out there like, yeah,
I hate that guy. He did X, Y, and Z. And I'm like, I, what I did, what, uh,
you've been put in charge of running, running,
heck heck the afterlife for people,
the afterlife for people, not evil enough for hell.
What's the first torture you design.
I'm not evil enough for help. Um,
uh, cut their tongues out. I just don't want to hear about it.
You know what I mean? I don't want to hear about it.
What would you do to get rid of the hell that's happening?
I cut off anything that sticks out, sticks out. Would you rather have half,
half your teeth or half year? Half your hair? My half my hair. I mean,
half my teeth. That would, that'd be a problem on many levels.
I'd rather have half my hair. All right. Thank you very much.